get ready to make some more heart
wrenching decisions Marvel and telltale
games have announced a partnership for a
new title that's due to launch in 2017
I'm Lucy and together let's explore
every dialogue option and our
environment for some more clues in this
gs news update those sneaky folks of
telltale have also published a blog post
about the announcement though it doesn't
offer much in the way of specifics they
wrote announced this evening in San
Francisco we're excited to reveal an
all-new partnership with the incredible
team Marvel Entertainment will be
teaming up on the development of an
upcoming telltale game series project
set to premiere in 2017 Marvel is just
the latest brand that telltale has taken
on others include major media franchises
like The Walking Dead game Thrones
Jurassic Park and minecraft
in February telltale announced that it
was moving beyond James of its new game
flash TV show hybrid project called
Super Show although it's unclear if the
new Marvel game will operate under this
model personally I'd like to see a
Dazzler or Squirrel Girl spin-off but I
guess a girl can dream which classic
Marvel characters would you like to see
telltale tackle let me know in the
comment section below and for all your
episode of gaming needs make sure to
keep it GameSpot